the world's 25 most valuable sports
Empires are worth in aggregate
$216 billion this year or an average of
8.6 billion per Empire that represents a
24% increase over last year it also got
a lot harder to make the list this year
the cut off was
4.95 billion 38% higher than last year
in order to be eligible for our list a
sports team team owner or a company has
to be the controlling owner of one
sports team worth at least $500 million
as well as own other sports related
assets worth at least $100
million here are the top five sports
empires in the world and number five is
Harris Blitzer sports and entertainment
increased
155% in value last year the biggest
increase among our 25 Empires Harris
Blitzer bought of course the Washington
commanders last year for a record $6
billion that NFL team complements its
portfolio of Crystal Palace the English
soccer team the Philadelphia 76ers in
the NBA and the New Jersey Devils in the
NHL perfectly giving Harris Blitz for
sports and entertainment a big franchise
in each of the four main team
sports number four is Jerry Jones Jerry
owns the Dallas Cowboys of course the
Cowboys are worth $9 billion they're the
most valuable sports team in all of
sports number three is Fenway Sports
Group Fenway Sports Group started
building its Sports Empire in 2002 when
it acquired the Boston and Red Sox since
then it's also bought Liverpool the
English soccer team and more recently
the Pittsburgh Penguins in the National
Hockey League each of these teams have
increased significantly in value since
they were acquired by Fenway Sports
Group number two on our list this year
is crony sports and
entertainment it's operated by Stan Kony
one of the richest people in the world
crony has a wide variety of sports
assets including in the NBA the NHL and
in addition the Rams in football last
year of course the Nuggets won the NBA
Championship crony also owns Sofi
Stadium home to the Los Angeles Ram Sofi
is the glitziest football stadium in the
NFL number one on our list this year is
Liberty Media whose Formula 1 racing
promotion we valued this past summer at
an average of
$1.88 billion per team that represented
almost a three-fold increase over the
valuation we gave those teams in
[Music]